hey everyone I'm Lacey and this is btw
on Vsauce this week I am talking about
online gaming specifically the people
that you meet online you know exactly
who I'm talking about they're the people
that are always there and they always
annoy you and yet they never go away
first there is the young gamer this is
the gamer that should have been in bed
about 20 minutes ago and yet here they
are still up gaming with you
you know how carnival rides have those
rides that you have to be certain
Heights to be on well how about we have
gaming that you have to have voices that
are like this low - game that will
eliminate them completely next you have
the guy that lives in his mom's basement
let's face it they're still out there
I know free rent is awesome but there's
times that you just need to get out just
get out then there's the guy that makes
fun of everybody's gamer tags this guy
no matter what your gamertag is he will
find something wrong with it and what I
have to say to you sir is if your
gamertag is pwned master 69 you should
not be criticizing anybody else's
gamertag next we have the guy that hosts
games even though his connection sucks
this guy shouldn't be hosting games and
yet he is so you end up either on the
ground in the corner you can't hear your
partner's you end up getting killed or
dropping dead even though you're not
dead so next we have the guy that places
music over his headphones now this guy
is one of my favorites because you know
what when I come into a lobby I want to
hear your music no really if you are
angsty and you're listening to Eminem I
love Eminem I'm just gonna pop open a
smirnoff ice and start chugging with you
because I know that's probably what
you're drinking if you're blasting
Eminem in a lobby of a game okay so next
we have the person that uses cheap
weapons to win battles this guy thinks
that the grenade launcher or the rocket
launcher is his best friend or that the
ghost in Halo is something that he
should constantly be riding the whole
entire game just because you're getting
more kills doesn't mean you're a better
player it just means that you're just
ruining every
else's gameplay and finally here's one
that really hits home for me guys that
hate on girl gamers I I know I made a
mistake and putting girl in my gamertag
but it doesn't mean I want you to talk
to me why don't you just save your
energy to beat me in the game right I'll
gladly talk to you if you can beat me
well that's all I have for you this week
bTW those really really obnoxious gamers
you could always just mute them